Israeli forces conduct tank raid in Gaza
ahead of expected Invasion I am not
going to play the stupid double speake
games with you you do not have video
even of Tanks storming through the
border and killing people and blowing
things up and say we didn't invade yet
that's quite quite literally you invaded
now they're trying to make this
distinction likely because they want to
downplay their actions and we know when
the word gets out it's not like the any
foreign country cares about what we call
it this is for the American people they
don't want the American people to hear
Israel has invaded Gaza US deploys
troops to the region so they say no no
no there's no Invasion yet just a tank
raid the tanks are just going for a walk
you know they they need to stretch their
legs test out their wheels so you know
it's not a big deal it's not an invasion
it's stop asking us questions it's an
incursion they know once the American
people hear words like World War III
there's no coming back